the next installment in the final
fantasy vii remake
is already in the works and will be in
our hands as soon as possible
season five for call of duty has been
teased and
all the rumors have finally been laid to
rest game pass is not coming to the
switch
or the ps4 i'm project and you've
reached your save state for tuesday july
21st
[Music]
in a recent fumitsu interview with some
of the key developers behind the final
fantasy 7 remake
they've confirmed that the game is not
only in full development
but they're trying to get it to us as
soon as possible some of the team's
obvious goals are to reach a higher
quality than the first installment but
they also made it clear that the new
story of final fantasy vii
has just begun this may explain a few
changes like madame m's massage scene to
fit raiding purposes
and the lack of avalanches hideout in
part one to help with cloud character
development
but this can also lead to a few new
surprises
the team confirmed a ton of various
details including some
almost spoilers that i don't really want
to mention here but
if you do want to read more on that then
you already know
you gotta go to gamespot.com competitive
streamer nick
merks revealed a short clip on his
stream recently
that may give us some hints behind
season five of call of duty the clip was
short but showcased a pov
from inside a train that looks like the
one in war zone ready for departure with
a chopper flying
overhead the date of august 5th is
displayed on the screen which is also
the final day of the current battle pass
it's not uncommon for new events to
launch on the final day of
ongoing content but we don't know what
that new event will be just yet
there have even been some rumors about a
loot train that's going to circle the
map which
doesn't really sound too far-fetched
considering the existence of loot trains
or in other popular brs like apex
legends
but i guess we'll just have to wait
until august 5th to see what's really
going on
and while we're on the topic of rumors
one big one has finally been laid to
rest
unlike the construction i have going on
right outside
and that is that game pass will not be
coming to the switch
or the ps4 the rumors popped up after
there was some xbox live support on
switch after its release of cuphead
and the ever-growing xbox ecosystem
game pass ultimate xcloud and mobile
devices have all become a part of the
xbox ecosystem
and with this expansion players began to
wonder if it could soon be
on any console phil spencer explained
that the game pass library would
really only fit on platforms that could
provide that full xbox live
experience and obviously competitors
like the switch and the ps4
don't want that full xbox live
experience on their hardware
which finally sets the record straight
that's a wrap on the news but before you
go make sure you check out
store.gamesbot.com
because we are selling awesome play for
all merch and all of those proceeds are
being donated to black lives matter and
19 relief efforts the donation drive is
still going to be open
until the end of august so if you don't
get a chance to snag something now you
still have
plenty of time thanks for watching you
can follow me on twitter at persia
underscore xo and
make sure of course you reach your safe
date tomorrow with your boy kurt
i'll see you guys next time peace out
you